pratique se fera page approximatif et
rotatif des pères dans la bagnole
nouveau montage vidéo montre gad elmaleh
qui raconte comment son père lui donner
des coups en voiture une histoire
racontée deux ans plus tôt par louis
josé houde
mais pour me calmer mon père appliquer
les techniques de nos squeeze à une
jambe par un arrêt à la même à chauvel
gad elmaleh ses gags et le volet selon
plusieurs humoriste gad elmaleh est un
voleur de blagues depuis un bon moment
déjà
il est dorénavant persona non grata au
bordel comedy club dont l'un des
copropriétaires martin petit semble lui
aussi avoir été plagiée par gad elmaleh
te jure je me promenais la tête pour son
rôle à euros
martin petit a réagi écrivant ceci je ne
suis pas fâché mais très gêné au final
ce n'est jamais drôle de perdre
camarades de travail cousin jean louis
josé houde n'a pas voulu commenter le
montage vidéo plagiat coïncidence ou
simple ressemblance dans le milieu de
l'humour il y a un réel malaise à parler
du sujet patrick huard était avare de
commentaires même si une première vidéo
diffusée la semaine dernière laissait
sous-entendre que gad elmaleh l'a déjà
copié ou lorient joue un mec se moucher
après regard pourquoi toute cette
polémique n'a pas empêché gad elmaleh
d'aller chercher lundi soir à paris un
prix pour l'ensemble de sa carrière lors
de la 14ème édition du prestigieux globe
de cristal il est resté muet sur ces
allégations de plagiat et il n'a pas
répondu à nos demandes d'entrevue
je pense pas qu'on peut celle qu'on
puisse éliminer de la même façon c'est
un grand performeur on vient les voir
parce qu'ils nomment et qu'on va saluer
la même façon le ca des repas comme un
grand créateur c'est sûr je pense que
son image vous êtes retraité né au maroc
les citoyens canadiens
gad elmaleh a une belle carrière
internationale et il a de nombreux
admirateurs en pleine tempête son ami
jerry seinfeld l'a défendu maintenant
que tu lis tu commences à penser à autre
chose avec ce montage vidéo qui
attaquent la crédibilité de gad elmaleh
ont été publiés par un français qui
utilise le pseudonyme de copies comique
et qui souhaite garder l'anonymat
il veut ainsi dénoncer le plagiat en
humour ici louis fait des primaires
radio canada montréal au trocadéro